the coffee harvesting season has begun
in South Sudan until now these farmers
near the border with the Democratic
Republic of Congo produced coffee for
the local market many welcome the
opportunity to sell it abroad it's much
better to harvest the coffee for export
here we just take it to the mill and get
paid that's it
exporting the coffee is easier than
drawing it on your own and then having
to look for a buyer here in South Sudan
the world's largest food corporation
Nestle has invested more than half a
million euros here that money has paid
for setting up three cooperatives
training farmers and teachers and
cultivating coffee plants for the first
plantations in the country the coffee is
still dried on site then the raw product
is sent to Switzerland where it's
roasted and ground and packed into
capsules the farmers themselves say they
can't afford this kind of coffee time to
harvest the coffee but then I also have
to go and take care of my subsistence
farm to grow food for my family food
prices are going up I can still just
about afford to buy some oil and salt at
the market over 90% of South Sudan's
land is said to be fertile but most of
the food consumed is imported at high
cost or provided by aid agencies that
makes consumers especially sensitive to
price fluctuations on the global market
many are dependent on charitable aid the
yayyyy agricultural training centre
wants to change that the local NGO is
financed by Norway trainers show farmers
how to make their fields more profitable
for the yeas principle coffee is simply
a byproduct
priority of the private sector is first
of all to fulfill the needs of the local
demand then that means that the next
step is now to go for cash crops that
can be imported to the outside countries
or international Nestle plans to invest
a further two million euros in South
Sudan the company hopes to train more
farmers to grow coffee for export